un techo bajo el que protegerse del frío
en torno a 1000 personas la mitad de los
migrantes situados en la frontera entre
polonia y belarús pasaron la noche en
este almacén fueron llevados hasta allí
por las autoridades de belarús y algunos
aseguran que están dispuestos a volver a
sus lugares de origen y pasar ahora
no lo sé pero yo me vuelvo a mi país lo
encontré
según fuentes diplomáticas de irak de
donde provienen muchos de los migrantes
unas 300 personas han expresado su
intención de ser repatriadas entretanto
sigue la tensión en el ámbito político
sideways y pugnas es simplemente un
ataque a las fronteras de la unión
europea nosotros estamos cumpliendo con
nuestra responsabilidad europea y espero
que toda la unión europea todos los
países miembros las realizaciones o las
opciones anímica entonces son costos las
instituciones se solidaricen con polonia
y nuestras acciones desde alemania sin
embargo se aboga por el diálogo con
minsk para ocuparse de la crisis
humanitaria pese a no reconocer la
legitimidad de lukashenko todo después
de que el martes los migrantes fueron
rociados con agua y gases lacrimógenos
desde el lado polaco
para mejorar esta preocupante situación
humanitaria de miles de personas tiene
sentido hablar también con quienes en
minsk tienen los medios para cambiar
esta situación sufren del joven mientras
los países siguen su juego de
acusaciones políticas el resto de
emigrantes sigue vagando en la frontera
a las puertas del invierno europeo